كيف حدث ذلك ، فالأمر
كله يتعلق بالتواصل بعد أن أذهل
الحكام في America's Got Talent
الثنائي Mentalist الذي دعا العقل إلى الذهن
عاد إلى الوطن في دبي ما هو سرك الذي
لن تخبرني به هل أنت
لا تريد حقًا ذلك؟  أعلم هل تعلم
بالطبع أريد أن أعرف ما إذا كنت تريد
الاحتفاظ بها ، لقد تحققت من خطأ الستائر الداخلية الخاصة بك ، لقد
تحققت من عدم وجود تقنية
وراء هذا ، على الإطلاق ،
كان جيمس ومارينا هارينجتون معًا لمدة
ست سنوات يقولون إن اتصالهم ساعد في
تطوير  القدرة على قراءة
عقول بعضنا البعض ولكن كيف حدث
ذلك كيف حدثت لحظة الاكتشاف هذه ،
لم نكن في حمام السباحة ، نحن في حمام سباحة ،
لقد كان لدي
يوم إجازة فقط ونحن نتحدث فقط وأدركنا
أننا  نقرأ عقول بعضنا البعض
بطريقة ما لم نكن نعرف ما كان عليه
في تلك المرحلة ، لكن بعد ذلك بدأنا
العمل عليه بشكل طبيعي كنت متشككًا
حتى هذه اللحظة عندما أخبرتني مارينا أن
رمز التحقق من البطاقة (CVC) ليس لي أيضًا ولكن
بطاقة زوجي البنكية الجنوب أفريقية تعتقد
بالنسبة لي ولكن في المرة الأخيرة التي تستخدم فيها هذه
البطاقة ، استمر في
التفكير من فضلك ،
وآخرها يمكن أن يكون ما هو عليه ،
أعني أن قسم الأرقام في هذا
الأمر برمته هو ما أثار دهشتي حقًا
هو كيف "  أنت قادر على التقاط
الأرقام التي يحملها جيمس ومن ثم
كيف تحصل على هذه المعلومات هل
تبدو مثل الصورة المرئية التي لا يمكنك وصفها حقًا في
بعض الأحيان ، أراها أحيانًا
يمكنني أن أشمها مثل كريم اليد الذي
تعرفه عندما  تنبعث منه رائحة طيبة
في بعض الأحيان ، وأنا أعلم ما
هي ، ونعم ، إنها خدعة غريبة ، إنها
خدعة قاموا بتضمينها في
عرضهم الجديد المسمى `` متصل '' الذي تم إطلاقه
على متن سفينة المحيط الشهيرة الملكة
إليزابيث الثانية في دبي
عندما كنا في فيغاس  أنه
كان هناك عروض سحرية وعقلية
في كل مكان ، وهذا شيء
ليس لديك في دبي ، والهدف من
العرض هو أننا جميعًا متصلون ،
إنه ليس مجرد شيء يمكننا القيام به
عندما تكون في موقف
تنتهي فيه من كل منهما  جمل الآخرين التي
تفكر بها في شخص مميز
ولم تتحدث معهم منذ شهور
وفجأة يتصلون بك ، النقطة المهمة
هي أن الحب هو أقوى شكل
من أشكال الاتصال ويمكن للأشخاص الذين يعيشون في الحب
تحقيق أشياء لا تصدق
خلال 90 دقيقة  عرض على هذه الروابط
حول بعض المشككين إلى مؤمنين ،
يبدو أنهم قالوا غير مؤمن وكنت
غير مؤمن تمامًا ، ثم
طُلب مني أن أصعد على خشبة المسرح ثم
غادرت الآن أعتقد أنني لا
أعرف كيف  يعمل ولكن يعتقد 100 شخص أنك
أتيت إلى مكان مثل هذا لتكون
مؤمنًا أو لا تكون مؤمنًا ، لا
يمكنك الاستمتاع بالترفيه هل هم
فنانين نعم وهم فنانون جيدون جدًا
بعد ترفيه الجماهير في جميع أنحاء
العالم هذا Mentalist Duo هو  حريصًا على
بناء قاعدة ثابتة في مشهد المسرح في دبي
إذا سألتنا قبل عامين
ما هو حلمنا ، فهذه ستكون أودري وأريد
فقط التوقف لفترة من الوقت
والاستمتاع بما لدينا الآن
وما هو التالي  فقط أكثر من
هذا